los nuevos datos económicos
estadounidenses contrastan con la
alegría mostrada por el presidente joe
biden el pasado 7 de enero si bien el
índice de desempleo se ubicó por primera
vez desde la pandemia por debajo de 4
puntos la inflación alcanzó durante el
año 2021 un aumento hasta el 7% el más
alto desde junio de 1982
los precios están subiendo y lo hacen a
un ritmo que supera el crecimiento de
los ingresos en los hogares en muchos
casos de
alimentos con un aumento de 6,3 por
ciento en el año la energía que pese a
una reducción en diciembre de 0,4 por
ciento cerró con 29.3 puntos y los
vehículos usados con 37 3% de aumento
fueron los rubros que más impactaron el
indicador la situación es una
consecuencia de la inyección de dinero
gubernamental que se combinó con una
baja tasa de interés y provocó un
aumento en la demanda de bienes a ello
se debe sumar los problemas en la cadena
de suministro especialmente para los
meses finales del año
y ya sabes en la oferta y la demanda es
economía básica no hay mucha oferta pero
hay una gran
presión en el 11 de enero jerome power
presidente de la reserva federal declaró
en el senado que el aumento en la tasa
de interés podría ser más rápido de lo
esperado ellos para frenar el incremento
de precios y evitar un impacto en la
recuperación del mercado laboral